greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and today we're going to talk about how
to set up goals in Google Analytics so
for this particular webinar we're gonna
jump into Google Analytics directly and
spend all of our time there because it's
about learning practical application so
goals are important goals let me just
say this goals are in analytics
something that should be aligned with
your business and we call goals that are
aligned with your business KPIs or key
performance indicators so it's very
important as a precursor that you know
how to set up goals in Google Analytics
because if you're using Google Analytics
you want to measure everything against
the goal so that'll further ado let's
jump right into Google Analytics so if I
go to Google Analytics and I log in okay
what I want to do is go down to admin
click on admin here and admin will take
you to basically a screen that looks
like this where you have a count column
you have your property column and then
your review column now the view column
is where you're gonna go to set up goals
okay so every view in every property has
up to 20 goals okay so by default and
analytics you're gonna have at least one
view for your property so if I have a
property I'm gonna have at least one
view but if I happen to set up multiple
views like you see here then I know for
every view I set up I have 20 goals to
work with so where are those goals so
under the view I'm gonna click on goals
and now I can see I have 20 at my
disposal now you can see here by
clicking on the recording column I can
see I have in this particular property
this particular view I have five goals
that are active so you can use up to 20
but you don't have to have 20
active okay you can have one active -
active my recommendation as least have
one goal again when you set up a goal
you're going to measure everything in
analytics against that goal okay so in
this case we have five particular goals
we're measuring so we have five active
out of twenty total so if I don't no
longer want to use a goal I could simply
just turn it off if I want to continue
using it just turn it on okay it's that
simple you could turn it on in off goals
so here I already have five set up so if
you want to set up a new goal the one
thing you need to know in Google
Analytics is in order to set up a new
goal okay you need to have edit access
at least the view level I would say at
the property level so you want to make
sure whoever is in charge of Google
Analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google Analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm gonna go to goals
and I want to set up a new goal before
we jump in and set up a new goal what is
it that we want to achieve that's really
the question we want to ask ourselves
what is the goal of the website well if
it's somebody downloading something okay
are you measuring that download vien
invent okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you somebody's registering
online or curry
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99% of the
time I'm just gonna choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free prefilled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that Thank You page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so imma say thank you page as
an example notice analytics is assigning
an ID so notice this is goal ID 15 that
means that that's the next available
goal there are 20 goals available in
analytics and so what analytics does is
they group goals together so one through
five six through ten 11 through 15 16
through 20 in chief goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 as part of
goal set for and why does Google
Analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data my
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected that I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through go ID five I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and
that one and now I'm gonna be able to
measure every goal I have active and go
set one against the channel so if I
choose goal set to whatever goals are
active their goal set three etc notice I
don't have any goals 16 through 20
active that are in goal set for
therefore I don't have that option
available to me so back to admin the
bottom left navigation again goals okay
we want to measure somebody going to the
Thank You page we have an edit access
we're gonna choose custom as our goal
setup we're gonna type in a goal name
I'm just gonna say thank you okay this
is goal 15 now this is the important
part Google Analytics has four different
goal types destination duration pages
per session or screens per session two
screens per session is related to mobile
because Google Analytics measures mobile
app activity and then you have an event
so we're going to cover all four of
these but for the sake of this simple
example I'm going to choose destination
why because if somebody goes to that
Thank You page we're gonna go ahead and
put in the Thank You page as the goal
the goal URL so for example destination
is my choice I'm gonna click continue
now this is where I'm gonna put the URL
so if my URL is just simply Thank You
dot HTML I can just go ahead and put
Thank You dot HTML or if it's just thank
you then I can just do thank you depends
on the website depends on the URI
structure so whatever that URL is that's
what you can put in and when you're done
you can verify it so what Google
Analytics does is actually will verify
over the last seven days
if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had 0% people go
to that page this is just an example
however if you didn't see a conversion
then you might want to make sure you
check the URL here that you
and if you do see a conversion rate then
you know it's working so Google
Analytics actually has options
so we're saying thank you is equal to so
the destination URL is equal to thank
you or thank you dot HTML or thank you
dot ESP or whatever that thank-you page
is okay you do have options so if you
have a long URL you can see it begins
with and you can see it begins with
slate thank you so this is the logic
we're gonna say hey if anybody goes to a
real rel that begins with thank you
think counting as a goal or you could
say equals two so if anybody goes to a
URL that equals two thank you
then count as a goal you have one more
option here regular expression so Google
Analytics understands the language of
regular expressions so regular
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
Analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with there
ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign ends
with or begins with so we can always do
that so you can use regular expressions
as well if you're familiar with regular
expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them but there are special
characters where that you can insert in
that are used as regular expression so
if you're not familiar with regular
expression don't choose that option you
can choose the other option of equals to
or begins with now note that on all
three of these options I didn't put the
domain so if my domain is AMA -
foundation org slash and then thank you
I don't need to put the domain because
analytics is our it already knows what
domain we're tracking so you don't have
to put in the domain here when you're
entering in in this case the goal URL so
you can omit the domain so when you put
in that URL you know that you have three
options to work with and then
you always always want to verify that
goal URL you always want to verify it
because if you see zero percent
conversion and in this case over the
last seven days then that should tell
you something either your goal is not
set up correctly or you just don't have
any conversion either way you want to
double-check that now when it comes to
the destination URL goal you do have an
option here for funnel so if I turn on
funnel then that means I have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if I have a cart and I want
to be able to track how many people go
in and add at the cart then I have the
option of adding specific pages as part
of the car so we could say you know step
one which is basically cart we could say
step two is filling information that
could be / filling we can see step three
shipping information / shipping and then
step four could be you know confirm and
that could be / confirmation so whatever
your URL structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessary have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting in a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I can see this is my funnel that
I've created for this particular goal
okay and the funnel is only available
for the destination your realm
so the funnel is available if you want
to see traffic through the goal okay and
how people go through the funnel and
where they drop off now you have an
option here to make the first step
require so if you make that first step
require then that means you're measuring
the funnel through the first step only
now if I turn that off then I'm
measuring the funnel through each step
meaning that I can measure people as
they drop in and out of the funnel where
it's required the first step that I'm
only measuring traffic as it enters
in the top of the funnel so you have
that option available to you the funnel
and then for all goals you do have a
value so if somebody did actually
convert okay Google Analytics is going
to count it as a conversion and you can
assign a value so if you're not an
e-commerce website then you may want to
think about assigning value if you are
an e-commerce website then analytics has
the ability to track ecommerce revenue
for your website so you don't need that
about you but in this case let's just
say your nonprofit organization and
you're collecting donations and on
average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to $5 well you can just go ahead
and put $5 in there as the value for
that goal so that means that if somebody
did go to in this example slash thank
you and convert analytics is going to
count it as a goal and then assign $5
value
alongside that goal so if you're not
ecommerce if you're saying nonprofit
like this organization or your b2b and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination your overall goal you have
the option of adding a funnel with all
goal types you have the option of adding
any value all goal types and we're gonna
go through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the three goal
types quizzing Google Analytics there
are four gold types and destination is
one of them with destination as you do
have the option with all go types is you
have to be able to choose your logic
here so we're gonna cover that with the
other three but just now when you set up
a destination URL goal you have the
option of adding a funnel now when you
actually do set up a funnel what's going
to happen is analytics is going to
measure traffic as a
through the funnel so where do you look
for that funnel information well you
want to get out of admin you want to go
to the left side navigation you want to
click on conversions then goals then
funnel visualization so based on the
funnel you set up you're going to be
able to see traffic as it goes through
the funnel so notice on this particular
funnel we don't have the first step
required why because I could see traffic
as it goes in and out of each step of
the funnel so let's go through this
funnel and see how people react so here
I can see the first step is the
storefront page
so over this particular period of time I
have 84 sessions
enter the store front page so out of
those 84 I can see 21 left the store
front page 63 went on to the next step
in the funnel which is the cart page I
can then see 24 people went on to the
cart page directly and 5 exited the site
altogether okay so that gave me 87 total
and from 87 I saw that 82 went on to the
next page with a next step what
analytics does is they give you a
percentage so in the first step we had
63 move on to the car page out of 84
that's 75% so from the cart page to the
create your account page we had 94% move
on so we didn't have anybody enter in
the create your account page we didn't
have anybody leave to create your
account page so we have 82 percent 80 to
create your account and then we have 82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent okay we have one exit so
if 81 that proceeded to beyond the
payment page which was purchased so 81
of 82 is 98 percent and we started with
84 so that gave us plus the 24 that we
accumulated along the way so they gave
us a 75% funnel conversion rate so 75%
of the people who entered in the funnel
went on to purchase okay so don't be
confused with the overall ecommerce
conversion rate so 75% is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
eighteen point four five percent over
this particular period of time why
because that takes into account all
sessions that have one to the website so
18 percent of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
funnel 75 percent converted so that's a
look at the funnel so if you set up a
funnel that's what it's going to look
like you have the option to measure
everything from step one and beyond or
measure as traffic goes in and out of
the funnel so the purpose of this is
we're going to be able to see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel
okay so that's the whole point of the
funnel and the funnel is available with
the destination URL goal so if I go back
to admin if I go back to goals under the
view I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we can see over
the past seven days nineteen percent
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
roulette a goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow
the measure is for example if we set the
goal to three pages per session then
we're going to be able to measure if how
many people went to the site and looked
at three pages per session so let's take
a look at that goal so if I open up the
goal here I could see three pages per
session is what we're naming it so
basically what we're asking analytics do
is anything greater than two pages which
would be 3 and Beyond count as a goal so
if anybody comes to the site looks at
more than two pages three pages or more
then it's going to count as a goal and
so here we can verify it so if we verify
it over the last seven days
we could see a four point one two
percent conversion rate and that tells
me that four percent of my traffic over
the last seven days looked at at least
three pages or more so you're probably
asking yourself well what number should
I put in for the actual variable so in
this case we see two well what you want
to do is you want to look at on average
let's just say a year today you want to
make sure you have statistical
significance so you want to look at a
period of time so if you go to analytics
go to audience okay and then if you go
to overview and if I change my date
range day year today I could see on
average right now I have one point two
one pages per session so that's on
average so we don't want to make our
goal one page we don't want to make our
goal two pages we want to make it three
so we want to be able to basically
measure at a higher rate okay why do we
want to measure at a higher rate because
if one point T 1 is the average then two
pages per session really isn't moving
the needle so what we really want to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at pages more during their session
so look at more pages and so we want to
be able to see what segment of the
audience is looking at more pay
what channel's driving traffic that's
looking at more pages what pages are
contributing to more pages per session
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working and then see what's not working
so you can make adjustments the whole
idea behind Google Analytics is to
improve website performance and so if
our average is 1.2 then if we change it
to just 2 it may not be good enough so
in this case you know we want to up the
bar a little bit so we're gonna choose 3
now you can choose 4 or 5 that's
perfectly fine just know if your average
is 1.2 I wouldn't choose one page per
session as my goal and I probably
wouldn't choose 2 so I'd set the bar a
little bit higher now the third goal
type available in Google Analytics is
also engagement related and that's
duration so just like pages per session
we can measure how long somebody stays
on the website and we could set up a
goal for that so in this case I have a
goal set for 1 minute 30 seconds so my
goal type is duration so if I click
continue then basically I'm asking
analytics in this case anybody who stays
more than one minute and 30 seconds on
the website count it as a goal and so
before you actually put in the number of
hours minutes and seconds you want to
look at that average so if you go back
to audience overview here I can see a
minute and 7 so do we want a minute 30
maybe we could do that maybe we can go
with 2 minutes so again the whole point
is you want to set the bar a little bit
higher than what the average is and so
here I can see over the last 7 days if I
verify this particular goal I can see 8
percent of my traffic over the last 7
days
stayed on the site at least 1 minute and
31 seconds ok they stay greater than 1
minute and 30 and so the whole point is
you can hone in because this is a goal I
can go in this is goal okay this is a
goal here and so I could see the
this is gold 13 so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is a
goal this is gold 13 so that would be in
goal set 3 so I can actually see what
channel is basically driving that goal
okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least 1 minute and 30 seconds
and so that's the whole idea behind
goals so likewise 4 pages per session we
can go into channels in here I can see
we've have a DH over this sheet period
of time here today pages per session we
have 3 percent conversion rate and here
I can see for example organic search has
a 13 percent conversion rate here I can
see social media has a 10 percent so I
can see that or people coming from
organic search are staying on the site
longer or they're looking at more pages
than any other channel so just like
duration or destination or any goal you
set up you can measure that goal against
any dimension just because it's
engagement doesn't mean you can't you
dab salutely can and so the whole point
of engagement where they goals is to
figure out what's driving traffic the
site but what traffic is engaging so you
want to be able to pinpoint that so you
can improve website performance now the
fourth goal type available in Google
Analytics is an event so if you click on
new goal include custom click continue
you have the option to choose an event
so an event is something that you can
measure on your website that analytics
can't measure by default so if you want
to measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with
an event then you want to be able to
turn that event into a goal so let's
quickly summarize what an event is so
again we want to be able to measure a
particular event that happens on the
website so in order to do so we need to
identify that event so if I go to for
example this particular website here and
I want to measure how many times
somebody clicks on the donate Now button
well if I met I can measure that as an
event so when you set up an event in
analytics you have to actually assign a
category and an action for that event so
that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event we let it go
first you need to set up the event and
in order to set up the event you need to
sign a category in action okay so once
you identify what you want to track as
an event on your website you're actually
going to go in a tag manager or have
your webmaster going to tag manager and
set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
in action and so here you can see we
have this set up our category is named
donate now interaction is click and
that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action clicked so when you actually do
setup an event you can go into analytics
and you could test that event so if I go
to the website and I click donate now ok
the reason why I have this as an event
is because I'm taking to a third party
website to handle the donations so here
I can go into analytics and now I can
see a category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal was
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name sounds the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm gonna click
continue I mean now that I've actually
have set up the event already in Google
tag manager I give it in a category I
give it in an action okay see here you
can see we have a regular expression
setup so anything with the header donate
or donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days of a point
eight one percent conversion rate okay I
could have easily put in equals two and
put in whatever the action what or the
category which is donate now now or I
could have put action equals click I
could have done that as well so let me
show you another example here so if I do
this custom continue events donate now
here's my goal ID it's going to be an
event so all I need to do is put in the
category in action so donate now and
then click so that's all I have to do
and that's my goal so I can verify it ok
to see if anybody's fired it and
basically that's what I need to do to
turn that event into a goal okay so you
need to set up for an event first you
need to identify the event set it up in
Google tag manager which is another
platform and once you've done that then
you have your category in action once
you have your category in action you
again going to go into analytics and
then simply put in that category and
action into the appropriate fields to
set up your event
related goal now all events don't have
to be turned into a goal if you actually
do set up an event and use not worthy a
goal meaning it's not a KPI or doesn't
align with your business goals well
don't fret you can always just go to
behavior okay you can always go to
events you can always go to overview and
measure your events that way so here you
can see all of our events that are fire
now we do have this one turn into a goal
so if it's important for our business
then we want to make sure we convert
that particular event into a goal okay
if it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is that
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value ok so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event in Google
tag manager you can see I'm a value set
up for one dollar then I can just go
into analytics and say you know what I
already have the value added so go ahead
and use the value added in Google tag
manager ok so I'm gonna choose yes now
if I choose now I have the option to add
the value here just like it would with
any other goal so just keep that in mind
you can add a value to any goal type
with an event where there you go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see enews that are signups
by channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions
okay so just know that you can align a
goal against any dimension so if you
have e-commerce you don't have to set up
for goal for that that's separate but if
you want to take a look at your goals in
analytics on its own you can just go to
conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example your today now I can
see based on the goals I've set up how
many total goal completions value which
takes into account the value we've added
into these goals
okay the total conversion rate and here
I can see it broken down by the goal I
actually have set up and I can see it by
page or I could see it by source of
medium so I can see Google organic is
driving the most goal completions then
Google CPC direct and then I could see
some others in here as well
contributing to goals now I do want to
point your attention to another report
in Google Analytics that does take into
account goals and that's multi-channel
funneling so again under conversion
goals multi-channel funnels if I go to
assisted conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another channel let's
just say email and
when they came back the email they did
convert during that session
well what analytics does is they give an
assist to organic search because they
help drive the traffic to the website so
it's similar to the game of basketball
if I have the ball and I pass it to my
colleague and my colleagues the one who
scores because they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
ie the conversion but I get an assist
and so analytics works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click or direct conversion but
they will give credits to the channel in
this case that assisted with the
conversion so that's under assisting
conversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the donate clicks only then
I'm gonna be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another reporting here top
conversion paths that I think it's
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to drive
conversions again this is year today so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together to
contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funnelling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year today happen on the
day somebody arrived on the website but
I can see I did get some conversions a
day later two days later etc so you have
time lag top conversion paths assisted
conversions they're all under
multi-channel funneling and they're all
available after you set up at least one
goal and so if you're not sure what goal
to set up ok don't fret
you can always at least set up and
gage Minh tral ated goal so that's
available to you
duration pages per session you also have
destination and event tracking and
they're all available to you you have 20
available per view now if you're not
quite sure exactly what type of goal to
set up there is an option available in
analytics and that's the gallery so you
can always import a goal from the
gallery so in other words we could take
a look at what other people have set up
in terms of goals so you just have to
click on the button import from gallery
and I'll take you to the gallery and
you'll be able to see what are the goals
others have set up now if you want more
information about how Google Analytics
works you can always take a look at a
webinar we did earlier the share Google
Analytics tutorial for beginners we go
into more detail about analytics and the
overview of analytics and we definitely
talk about goals so take a look at this
webinar and you know get some more
insight about not only goals but how
analytics works in general so I want to
thank you for paying attention today
getting a better understanding about
Google Analytics goals and how they work
I always think it's important to learn
about goals in general because if you're
using Google Analytics you definitely
need goals so thank you for paying
attention if you have any comments feel
free to put them underneath this video
if you need more information simply go
to simply learn comm thank you very much
and I'll see you soon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here